A widow, Mrs. Dashwood, and her three daughters,...
...Elinor, Marianne and Margaret moved in with the Middletons, who are distant relatives.
Elinor was sad to leave because she had become close to Edward Ferrars.
Elinor and Marianne met Colonel Brandon and John Willoughby.
Willoughby courted Marianne and they showed off their love for each other.
Willoughby departed for London on business, leaving Marianne lovesick and miserable.
Anne and Lucy Steele, relatives of the Middletons, visited Barton Park, which was the Middletons's home.
Lucy and Elinor became close friends.
Lucy told Elinor that she was secretly engaged to Edward Ferrars.
Later, when Edward's mother found out that he was engaged,...
...she decided to leave her fortune to Robert, Edward's younger brother, when she dies.
Elinor and Marianne traveled to London, where everyone was talking of Marianne's engagement to Willoughby.
Willoughby, however, denied that he ever had any feelings for Marianne.
Brandon explained that Willoughby was callous and corrupt.
Having squandered his fortune, Willoughby became engaged to Miss Grey, a wealthy woman.
Marianne developed a severe cold and became deathly ill.
When Willoughby heard of this, he visited her and asked forgiveness.
It turned out that Lucy actually married Robert Ferrars, not Edward.
Edward and Elinor were married, as were Marianne and Brandon.